[Music]
what you're saying is he's part of a a
whole system that is not just harvey
weinstein at all it's like a lot of
people are participating in this yeah
like everybody
yeah
what is it called
yeah well that's that was kind of that
was yeah that was kind of the point
exactly so
at what point do you recognize it's not
just this creepy
movie mogul it's like everybody the well
very quickly when i i flew home i
i didn't go to any of the other
premieres i had at sundance that time i
went home
and
um
i went to the management office of my
managers at that time and the head
manager they were very powerful
i said to him you know what happened and
i was like you know shell shocked and
like
and he and the first thing out of his
mouth the
god damn it i just had an la times
expose on him killed he owes it to me
not to do this
whoa and then i was like
that's when i started figuring out
everybody was in on it
wow so then i said i want i want the
lapd i want to talk to a criminal
attorney i want somebody to tell me what
my rights are here and of course you
know at that time like if i come out and
said in the press like please like
nothing would happen obviously it wasn't
the time societally certainly is not the
time there not that it ever was
and so um
my old assistant like three years ago
she's like uh she's a lesbian and she
that the woman that came in that
presented as working for the lapd
uh in a black suit like kind of a short
hair like lesbian woman um
she goes you're an actress you've done a
nude scene you're done
and she wasn't wrong i knew she was
right i was like
yeah you're right
so um then i found out quickly that he
was offering to anybody he'd done this
to a million dollars that was his number
that was his standard offer
and you had to sign a non-disclosure
agreement which means you cannot talk to
your therapist your boyfriend your mom
anybody in your life for the rest of
your life you cannot tell them this
monstrous thing happened to you keep it
inside
so i was like
i'm gonna trick him
so i played really dumb and requested a
hundred thousand dollars
in return for not signing an nda
so i became very quickly as number one
enemy because then the movies i had done
that hadn't come out yet hit and i got
very famous very quickly so then i'm i'm
dangerous to him
so from that point on your former guest
anthony pelicano
he was hired actually um
to work with the inquirer to keep
dossiers on me he bought off this has
also been exposed by ronan farrow uh who
i have my own quibbles with maybe we'll
get there uh
to he would like say from anyone from
gray and carter to somebody any
journalist in in america
graydon carter
at the time was the powerful very
powerful very powerful scumbag so
all these journalists from both like
from anywhere from the new york times to
the inquirer to people
to us weekly any of these kind of things
he would say
uh he would option one of their
stories they'd written and say i'm going
to turn this into a movie i'm going to
win you a lot of oscars oh by the way
here's my hit list if this person ever
appears like
a red carpet or there's a paparazzi
photo of them write the most disparaging
disgusting stuff he had a list i was
number one on his list of the red lines
for my name
and he was not wrong
i am a very formidable enemy
yeah well you turned out to be
that's for sure i mean the thing is it's
like dude you built this yeah i didn't
want to be like this you think i want to
talk about this stuff you think this is
fun
and what planet is that fun right
no but somebody has to do it and i know
when i was 11 i used to study napoleon
genghis khan alexander the greatest
battle plans i had like venn diagrams on
my walls and ceilings with threads and
pins like steady so it must be kind of
weird when all this breaks and all these
people are like oh i can't believe it
you know this is like shocking
there was a 16 year old girl from
australia
that tweeted at me she was i'm 16 and i
work in a coffee shop in australia after
he was exposed and even i knew
so what do you make of this like
what do you make of it
what are what are your thoughts and
their morals
i think i'm not a conspiracy nut well
first of all i'm not sure what to make
of some of it like the outlines i don't
know enough because i've never lived in
that world i've just brushed up but you
know
that he was protected by hillary and
bill clinton that he was protected by
david boyce uber 100 david is a true
sleazeball i'm suing him in under in
federal court you should and black cubed
you should you should so but it's like
it's like the it's like the he's
protected by the democratic party
you know why
that's what i don't understand
so for me like i
i think my opponents do not understand
my motivations at all they've tried to
buy me off every way in fact gavin
newsom's ex-wife before the weinstein
story broke because they knew i was
coming because i was heading out for
like three years at hollywood very
publicly in in the in the press yeah um
and so people all of a sudden acted like
i just spoke up the first day they read
about weinstein i'm like
no i've been rattling their cages
because i had to train people in the
media to listen to me differently
because if they just saw me as an
actress the first day this would all not
have worked i had to set up a domino
effect worldwide i wanted to show people
that if you fight and are strategic and
very smart about it you can cut off the
head of rotten power instead of just
biting at the ankles of the picket sign
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else